we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's a
very funny voicemail of related to the
alt-right take a listen to this hello
this is richard i wanted to know do you
think that the old rate has any anything
going for them like i think they're
right about anything because it does
seem to me that you know there's
differences between races and what were
white why shouldn't we listen to them
and respond to them thanks so listen
this is something that comes up
sometimes and this is one of these areas
where if I want to I could say you know
what I may disagree with the alt-right
on most things but we agree that oxygen
is necessary for human life so they're
not all bad what is often missing from
these conversations of but David can't
you find X or Y that you agree with with
such a political group and if you agree
on those things maybe they're not all
bad the point is what defines a
political movement is what makes it
different from others so coming up with
a list of areas with which I in which I
am in agreement with the alt-right on
relatively insignificant
non-controversial things doesn't really
tell us anything about the value of the
alt-right as a movement but when it
comes to what defines the alt-right what
the alt-right represents culturally and
socially and just to the agree that they
have economic policy economically it's
bad period that's it so like yeah I mean
I can come up with things where I would
probably agree with almost anyone who is
not severely disturbed mentally and
disconnected from the real world but
that's not really a value when we're
trying to figure out what political
movements what cultural movements what
societal movements are going to push us
in a positive direction rather than a
negative one so I don't know there's
probably something that the alt-right
gets right kind of by default most
humans get something right by default
the broken clocks are Right twice a day
but with regard to the defining
characteristics of the alt-right and the
movement and the vision
they have of what they want to change
the things they want to change that
distinguish them everybody can say well
we're against corruption okay most
people would at least say that it's not
really controversial the unique defining
characteristics are basically all bad
we've got a great bonus show for you
today Donald Trump says he is going to
look to cut the defense budget in the
future now the problem is he may not
even understand the reality of when we
talk about the defense budget there's
rarely ever serious discussions about
cutting it there are discussions about
slowing down the rate at which the
defense budget is growing and I don't
even think Trump understands that but
we'll talk about that on the bonus show
we will talk about the newly released
Ronald Reagan tapes where he refers to
those monkeys from African countries
meant to get to this on yesterday's
bonus show and didn't we will also talk
about a ten-year-old boy who is charged
with assault for injuring a classmate in
a dodgeball like game those stories and
many more including the latest updates
with the YouTube CNN twitch Fiasco that
we've been embroiled in all on the bonus
show two ways to get access to the bonus
show become a member at WWJ impact
muncom become a patron at patreon.com
slash david pakman show look forward to
speaking to you then